bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour une
nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'actu sur
tvfils 78 voici les principaux titres de
ce 24 septembre tableau numérique
tablette Élancourt cheveux ville
pionnière des nouvelles technologies à
l'école et ce matin le maire de la ville
a reçu le recteur de l'académie afin de
faire un bilan mais aussi des mots clés
de nouvelles pistes jusqu'au 29
septembre 600 acteurs mobilisés en
Île-de-France afin de réaliser sur le
terrain des flash tests se dépistage
rapide et gratuit du VIH dans l'Hexagone
en estime à 50 000 le nombre de
personnes ignorant vivre avec la maladie
invité de cette édition le président de
l'association HF prévention qui
participe à l'opération dans le
département et nous parlerons
environnement à la fin de ce journal
avec un reportage sur l'envers du décor
d'une station d'épuration comment sont
traités les eaux usées réponse à
Maurepas l'image du jour à présent
l'image de ce 24 septembre elle est
signée Olivier Maniscalco et le tournage
d'un téléfilm qui se déroule
actuellement à Saint-Quentin jusqu'au 8
octobre elle la réalisatrice Claire de
La Rochefoucauld qui a déjà signé
plusieurs épisodes de la série télé ris
scientifique prépare VOG pour France 2
avec notamment la comédienne Virginie
hoc qui a joué dans incognito avec
Franck Dubosc Bénabar il sera question
cette fois-ci de femmes opérés du cancer
du sein et de leur parcours pour
reprendre goût à la vie une comédie
sociale et sentimentale annoncée laisse
par la société dogside production ce
sera à découvrir sur les écrans de
France Télé en 2014
et l'encours ville pionnière dans le
domaine des nouvelles technologies à
l'école a reçu aujourd'hui la visite du
recteur de l'académie de Versailles
tableau numérique tablette également et
maintenant robot humanoïde c'est la
dernière innovation en date et Yolaine
Torres Elodie moine ont fait sa
connaissance
nous voici à l'école numérique
d'Élancourt des robots appelés Nao
viennent de faire leur rentrée et
peuvent raconter des histoires
sur la pelouse une série d'un grand
vacarme je bondis hors du lit pour avoir
ce qui se passait
si on a franchi le pas de leur numérique
depuis 10 ans déjà aujourd'hui la ville
va encore plus loin avec ce tout nouveau
robot objectif développer le goût des
sciences de l'ingénieur chez les enfants
les enfants vont le programmer et donc
dès que vous faites un travail et que
oui résultat tout de suite un robot qui
change de comportement vous imaginez le
pour l'apprentissage c'est idéal c'est
très concret et vous développez
l'intelligence logique aux mathématique
autre innovation de la rentrée 2000
tablettes numériques pour tous les
élèves de l'école élémentaire chacun y
stocke ses propres lectures ses poésies
mais aussi des documents audio et vidéos
un outil très pratique mais qui ne
remplace pas nos bons vieux cahiers les
enfants doivent continuer à écrire c'est
très important de continuer à écrire
donc c'est un support supplémentaire
et non pas tous
acquis les compétences tous en même
temps donc moi par exemple je peux
varier choisir les exercices donc là ça
va personnaliser oui mais dans le bon
dans le bon sens
renferme les élèves pourront même
emmener leur tablettes à la maison mais
uniquement pour travailler sur leur
leçon
et que pensez-vous justement de cette
idée de distribuer des tablettes
numériques dès le plus jeune âge à
l'école cela peut-il aider faciliter
l'apprentissage c'est notre question du
jour vos réponses fut-il très futile je
pense qu'il y a suffisamment d'écrans de
télévision pour les enfants pour ne pas
qu'on en rajoute à l'école pour moi
personnellement
ça ça a aucun intérêt à trois ans et
demi à 4 ans et demi on en faisait des
bas lors de la réunion des parents
d'élèves c'est je trouve que c'est pas
du tout utile à partir de 6 ans à la
rigueur
d'avoir ça donc je pense que Pluton
démarre mieux ça peut être c'est
beaucoup trop jeune
si le taux numérique
après ils ont pu savoir se servir d'un
crayon de d'un bout de papier enfin je
trouve ça serait dommage quoi ça fait un
besoin surtout bien souvent à la maison
ils ont la tablette des parents ou des
ou des grands frères des grandes soeurs
donc ils ont déjà à la maison donc si
déjà ils l'ont à l'école en plus ça fait
beaucoup
alors que le Mali est toujours marqué
par le récent conflit militaire en
France on se penche sur son avenir et
sur les ressources qui lui permettront
d'aborder au mieux une période de
transition attrape dans les Yvelines une
rencontre débat était ainsi organisé par
une association le thème la culture du
coton Olivier Maniscalco et le dis-moi
samedi dernier attrape se tenait d'une
rencontre ciné débat sur le thème de la
culture du coton au Mali un documentaire
réalisé par Jean-Michel Rodrigo était
projeté pour évoquer les difficultés que
rencontre le pays africain face à un
concurrent de poids les États-Unis cette
bataille du coton qui ressemble à celle
de David contre Goliath oppose d'un côté
les minuscules l'opin de terre des pays
d'Afrique de l'Ouest parmi les plus
pauvres du monde de l'autre côté les
champs qui s'étendent à perte de vue du
géant américain au moyen imposants et
bien des effets nous a laissé faire de
faire entendre la voix des paysans afin
qu'ils puissent bénéficier réellement du
fruit de leurs effort et de dire aux
Américains que les subventions est en
train de décimer la population paysanne
au Mali les villageois qui n'ont pas
d'autres ressources que le coton et puis
les États-Unis subventions de coton plus
la famille malienne c'est l'islore plus
la pauvreté devient grande moins
d'enfants à l'école il y a pas de santé
vraiment la subvention est un véritable
est une véritable catastrophe pour les
présidents du Mali
de ce qu'a vécu la Côte d'Ivoire et le
Mali donc c'est plus par rapport au
peuple ils ont que je m'intéresse mais
je savais pas que il y avait cette
difficulté au niveau du coton il faut
continuer au contraire c'est important
de d'ouvrir un petit peu les yeux
des Français en général
aux problèmes de l'humanité après la
projection du film était organisée un
défilé de tenue malienne et une
démonstration traditionnelle de fileuses
de coton comme pour illustrer un peu
plus le déséquilibre entre les deux pays
à noter que le Mali est à l'honneur dans
les Yvelines ce pays est l'invité
d'honneur des cinquième assises Yvelines
partenaire du développement qui se
tiendront à Marie le roi le 12 octobre
prochain politique et les deux
principales formations qui s'organisent
dans le département pour les municipales
tout d'abord l'UMP qui vient
d'officialiser la candidature de la
dyslas Square à Guyancourt jeune avocat
aussi ville il se présente également
sous les couleurs de l'UDI c'est sa
première candidature l'attache s'annonce
difficile pour lui au précédentes
élections le maire sortant le socialiste
François de Ligny avait totalisé 73% des
suffrages au premier tour côté PSE
justement les potentiels candidats à
l'investiture dans les Yvelines avaient
jusqu'à hier minuit pour se faire
connaître auprès de leur fédération les
primaires se tiendront ensuite le 10
octobre dans les sections locales quatre
candidats sont cependant déjà investis
afin d'avancer dans leur campagne c'est
le cas de Bernard ansara plaisir qui
entend profité au passage de la
démission de Joël la Réunion pour son
adjointe en cours de mandat en revanche
la situation est plus compliquée à
Maurepas notamment où le secrétaire de
section her et le conseiller général PS
Ismaïla vannes sont en concurrence
semaine de dépistage dépistage du VIH en
Île-de-France jusqu'au 29 novembre
l'opération était a lancé hier à Paris
en présence de Clos des vins le
président de l'agence régionale de santé
également de Jean-Luc cromero président
du Centre d'information de prévention du
sida dans la région et une opération
particulière puisqu'elle se veut la plus
importante jamais réalisée à l'aide de
flash test moins d'une minute elle
suffit pour obtenir un résultat sur le
terrain concrètement 110 sites accueille
le dispositif notre invité ce soir je
revendrai bonsoir à vous président
d'achref une de ses associations
partenaires vous allez aller à la
rencontre du public à Saint-Germain ou
encore à Mantes tout au long de la
semaine mais pour débuter je vous
propose d'écouter Clos des vins et
Jean-Luc Romero nous parlait de ce
rendez-vous
c'est d'aller au plus proche des gens et
notamment des populations vulnérables
pour leur permettre de se faire dépister
d'avoir des informations et de les
rapprocher du système de santé on sait
qu'il y a un certain nombre de gens qui
ont beaucoup de mal à approcher le
système de santé pour des raisons qui
sont parfois difficiles à comprendre
aujourd'hui il faut leur montrer que sa
voix c'est mieux que de pas savoir et
que vous savez moi je j'ai appris ma
séropositivité il y a 25 ans il y avait
pas de traitement je comprends qu'à ce
moment-là les gens avaient peur parce
que quelque part c'était comme un arrêt
de mort aujourd'hui on sait que on peut
vivre et survivre avec le sida même si
ça reste une maladie mortelle et donc il
faut que ces populations comprennent que
chacun comprenne qu'il vaut mieux savoir
que de pas savoir au-delà de cette
semaine de sensibilisation il est
possible d'avoir accès à ce test de
dépistage rapide auprès d'associations
qui ont été agréés qui ont été formés
pour pouvoir faire ces tests et d'autre
part pour pouvoir accompagner et donner
l'information à la personne qui serait
identifié comme étant séropositive et
ces associations leur référence sont
accessible sur le site de Sida Info
Service ici dans la région donc cette
semaine est une semaine de
sensibilisation mais tout au long de
l'année l'accès aux tests rapides est
possible on vient d'entendre donc deux
de ses acteurs de cette opération de
flash test de dépistage rapide du sida
Jean-Luc Romero disait que certaines
personnes avaient peur de savoir est-ce
que c'est votre avis vous le constatez
sur le terrain alors oui effectivement
c'est vrai que les gens ne souhaitent
pas savoir et c'est pour ça que c'est
important aussi d'emmener le dépistage
au plus proche des populations c'est ce
qu'on fait nous aussi toute l'année
comme le disait claudevin on fait ça
toute l'année parce que à un moment
donné savoir c'est aussi pouvoir mieux
accepter le soin mieux se rendre donc
sur donc de l'accès aux soins et ça
reste primordial aujourd'hui comment ça
se passe concrètement c'est flash test
on en avait déjà parlé sur ce plateau
mais peut-être rappeler le procédé alors
donc flash test c'est toute l'année chez
HF prévention nous on le propose sur des
lieux de rencontres extérieurs on le
propose aussi sur les centres
commerciaux les universités les cœurs de
cité et l'idée c'est effectivement qu'en
une minute
une minute c'est le temps de la
manipulation du test on est au courant
si la personne effectivement et c'est
repositives ou non une minute c'est le
temps du test mais il y a un petit
entretien qui dure un quart d'heure 20
minutes une demi-heure ça peut être des
fois plus long en fonction aussi des
besoins de la personne puisque l'idée
c'est de faire de la prévention et donc
de la réduction des risques outre le
fait de dépister donc des gens c'est
fiable c'est fiable c'est aussi fiable
quand laboratoire on ne cesse on cessera
jamais assez de le dire c'est important
que les gens se fassent dépister c'est
comme si on avait apporté un laboratoire
en version rapide sur des lieux où
effectivement des lieux de vie hier on a
fait ça et vous êtes venus le filmer à
50 ans en Yvelines espace Saint-Quentin
nous a encore ouvert donc ses portes on
fait ça aussi des fois à la fac de
Saint-Quentin vendredi on fera ça au
marché du Val Fourré et on souhaite être
vraiment au plus proche des publics qui
pour nous aussi sont parfois des publics
cibles et on sait que en général un
centre de dépistage fait 0,2 % de
personnes donc séropositives nous sur
les centres commerciaux les universités
on est à 1,5% effectivement hier on a
dépisté des personnes séropositives
c'est jamais agréable d'entendre qu'on
essaie au positif et pourtant il gagne
aussi en espérance de vie le fait d'être
mis sous médicaments et de pouvoir être
en plus rapidement traité effectivement
ça permet d'avoir un traitement et de
pouvoir vivre donc plus longtemps donc
on augmente ce qu'on appelle la
durabilité le dépistage qui est gratuit
on va le repréciser également et gratuit
on apprend très rapidement ça
séropositivité le plus difficile c'est
sans doute de se l'entendre dire vous
nous expliquerez comment vous annoncer
justement ces résultats juste après
cette autre interview de Jean-Luc Romero
le président du centre d'information et
de prévention du sida en Île-de-France
beaucoup de ces tests sont faits par des
souvent par des militants associatifs
par des personnes qui sont parfois
concernées par cette maladie et qui en
plus ont les mots parce que vous savez
faire un test c'est toujours quelque
chose de très difficile en plus vous
pensez que vous pouvez être séropositif
et vous avez souvent en face de vous et
en tout cas dans cette opération des
gens qui savent ce que c'est souvent que
d'apprendre une séropositivité parce
qu'ils l'ont parfois appris à prix
eux-mêmes donc je crois que c'est en
tout cas c'est très sécurisant pour ça
chacun et j'espère que beaucoup vont
faire c'est ces tests durant cette
durant cette semaine les personnes que
vous accueillez sur ces différents sites
pour le dépistage vous les prenez en
charge aussi moralement il y a tout un
accompagnement bien sûr non seulement il
y a un accompagnement mais en plus on va
les emmener directement aux soins par
exemple hier effectivement on a pris
directement des rendez-vous peu importe
l'heure on a des professeurs qu'on
connaît principalement sur Paris qui
accepte de prendre des gens qu'on a
dépisté un peu en urgence entre
guillemets donc dès le lendemain sont
des gens qui sont pris en charge et mis
dans le circuit de soins pour
qu'effectivement ils puissent être mis
sous une trithérapie puisque aujourd'hui
meurt toujours du sida c'est important
de le dire sauf quand on est bien
dépisté et qu'on va vers le soin vers
donc les médicaments Jean-Luc Romero qui
est d'ailleurs président d'honneur chez
HF prévention disait vrai effectivement
nous à chaque prévention il n'y a pas de
médecin ce sont donc des personnes qui
sont bénévoles ou salariés qui sont
habilités à ça et qui effectivement sont
formés et habilités à pouvoir faire donc
ce type de test vous l'avez évoqué
brièvement tout à l'heure mais quels
sont les types de lieux sur lesquels
vous intervenez le but c'est d'aller
rencontrer le public on le rappelle ce
sont des dépistages qui se déroulent sur
le terrain ce ne sont pas dans les
hôpitaux l'hôpital vient directement au
public le test vient au public vous
intervenez les centres de dépistage
aussi anonym et gratuits notamment
durant flash test pour que les médecins
sortent un petit peu de l'hôpital et on
intervient donc sur des parkings forêt
aire d'autoroute ça c'est notre
spécificité on ne va sur les lieux de
rencontre extérieure et on intervient
aussi depuis peu sur tout ce qui va être
donc coeur de cité donc au pied des des
immeubles donc de de cité où il y a
beaucoup de migrants on va intervenir
aussi
université je rappelle aussi qu'il y a
beaucoup de prostitutions dans les
universités plus de 2% des élèves quand
même et on vient maintenant aussi donc
sur les centres commerciaux et
effectivement c'est important parce
qu'on se rend bien compte que sur des
centres commerciaux bah c'était aussi
des lieux de vie et c'est aussi des
lieux où les gens ont besoin de se faire
dépister des lieux de rencontre
également que vous avez évoqué on a vu
quelques images il y a quelques instants
sur l'un de ces lieux de rencontre des
lieux de consommation de sexe où vous
intervenez pour rappeler aussi alors
c'est important on le dit jamais assez
les gens pensent que ce sont des hété
enfin des gays qui vont sur ces lieux de
rencontres extérieur je rappelle quand
même qu'il y a 80 % ce sont des
hétérosexuels père de famille et que du
coup la prévention est importante parce
qu'ils ne sont pas habitués à mettre le
préservatif ce ne sont pas des publics
qui sont habitués à rentrer chez eux
forcément c'est bien mais il faut pas
oublier l'élément essentiel de
préservatif forcément exactement et
c'est important donc de réduire les
risques et la prévention n'est qu'un
outil aussi pour réduire les risques
vous êtes intervenus sur le terrain hier
à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines notamment je
vous propose de voir comment se passe
concrètement le travail d'achève
prévention l'un de ces flash test
c'était à Saint-Quentin hier bonjour on
propose un test de dépistage rapide
c'est anonyme c'est gratuit et la
réponse est immédiate si ça vous
intéresse
une piqûre sur le doigt et la réponse
est donnée immédiatement l'association
HF prévention va directement chercher
les gens pour leur proposer un test de
dépistage
vous voyez tout est une terre
deux trois gouttes de sang sont
prélevées puis mélangés à des réactifs
une minute après la personne c'est tout
de suite si elle est séropositive ou non
comme j'avais déjà fait mon test il y a
6 mois je suis pas d'appréhension je
vais faire le test quand même pour
savoir si depuis le changement moi je
suis passé ici par hasard je savais pas
qu'ils étaient ça me permet de faire un
test plus régulièrement parce que des
fois j'y pense mais j'ai pas le temps
alors que là ça prend une minute c'est
un test qui est extrêmement rapide
pour moi avant cela passage obligé avec
les animateurs de l'association il
rappelle quelques règles de prévention
et de réduction des risques dans un
centre de dépistage classique deux
personnes sur 1000 ont été dépistées
séropositives depuis le début de l'année
dans le département
HF prévention en se déplaçant sur les
universités les coeurs de cité ou les
centres commerciaux comme ici on a
dépisté en moyenne presque 10 fois plus
on se rend bien compte que le centre de
dépistage anonymé gratuit c'est quand il
y a une prise de risque que les gens y
vont ils n'y vont pas forcément
spontanément or aujourd'hui il y a entre
50 et 60000 personnes qui sont
séropositives mais qui ne connaissent
pas leur statuts sérologique dans le
cadre de la Semaine flash test
l'association continue son périple
jusqu'à dimanche ce mardi elle sera à
l'étendue Cora à Saint-Germain-en-Laye
jusqu'à 21h merci beaucoup mais je vous
en prie
à tous vos amis et tout ça je leur dirai
de passer merci beaucoup merci bonne
journée
à chaque prévention qui intervient donc
encore aujourd'hui on a entendu dans ce
reportage reprécise aussi que vous serez
à Saint-Germain-en-Laye ce sera ce sera
jeudi et ensuite sur le marché du Val
Fourré exactement à côté de
Mantes-la-Jolie on revient juste sur
l'opération qui s'est déroulée hier
qu'elles ont été les résultats on a fait
à peu près 109 ans on va pas faire à peu
près on a fait 109 dépistage alors
effectivement on a eu deux positifs donc
c'est toujours compliqué d'annoncer donc
des SR oppositivité mais effectivement
après les personnes sont mis sous
traitement donc ce qui est quand même
important on sait déjà que les personnes
ont été prises en charge donc ce qui est
quand même primordial et donc c'est des
personnes qui effectivement après on
doit annoncer aussi à leur conjoint donc
c'est jamais facile souvent on a des
personnes qui sont dépistées et après on
a les conjoints qui viennent nous voir
ou qui sont après mis dans la boucle ou
pas mais après c'est profil justement il
y a pas de profil type adressé parce que
tout le monde est concerné forcément il
y a un profil type qui est donné par le
ministère donc on va proposer un test à
l'ensemble de la population et après
effectivement on peut en fonction de ça
cibler on sait par exemple que pour vous
donner quelques chiffres sur ces lieux
de rencontre on a donc les lieux de
rencontre extérieurs on a on est à 387%
depuis le début de l'année sur les
centres commerciaux les universités on a
1,5% et sur les zones de prostitution
type Saint-Germain-en-Laye etc on est à
8 % depuis le début de l'année c'est une
véritable hécatombe de personne qui ne
connaissaient pas leur statut
sérologique et qui sont séropositives
donc là c'est 50000 personnes en France
qui ne connaissent pas
les chiffres varient des fois on nous
dit 30000 40000 50
000 je pense qu'il y en a beaucoup trop
ce qui est sûr c'est que pour se
protéger il faudrait se protéger c'est
une première chose connaître son statut
sérologique c'est quand même super
important nous on est des créateurs à la
limite d'événements sur ces centres
commerciaux ces universités où on crée
le moment où on n'avait pas prévu de se
faire dépister et boom on va se faire
dépister et ça c'est important et et du
coup ça permet vraiment que les gens
connaissent leur statut sérologique très
rapidement parce sinon effectivement au
centre de dépistage il y a effectivement
une semaine d'attente je rappelle quand
même qu'à l'Institut de promotion de la
santé sur rendez-vous vous pouvez
appeler HF prévention sur rendez-vous le
matin on peut vous recevoir pour faire
un test rapide et ça c'est toute l'année
donc faut pas hésiter à trappe donc on
doit hors de cette opération flash test
2013 qui est mené sur la région vous
pouvez bien évidemment contacter
l'association l'IPS l'Institut de
promotion de la santé les informations
pratiques qui sont affichées à l'écran
flash test 2013 c'est une opération qui
est aussi menée dans d'autres régions en
Guyane dans le PACA Rhône-Alpes
également le tout début de l'opération
c'était en Île-de-France l'an dernier
exactement bilan avait été plutôt bon ça
veut dire qu'il y aura tous les ans ce
type d'opération au départ c'était
Sidaction c'est important de le rappeler
Pierre Berger avait souhaité monté une
semaine de dépistage et avait demandé
aux opérateurs en l'occurrence à chef
prévention mais aussi aide de bien
vouloir se mobiliser en faveur du
dépistage ce que nous nous avions fait
très rapidement on avait mobilisé
grandement nos équipes là-dessus ça a
tellement remporté
c'est la meilleure des prévention merci
à vous merci à vous santé toujours santé
et active le dispositif de la caisse
primaire d'assurance maladie des
Yvelines qui proposent à des assurés
sociaux en bonne santé des informations
pratiques et des ateliers par exemple
autour du cœur du dos de la nutrition
faite son millième adhérent un résultat
encourageant pour ce dispositif qui mise
sur l'idée qu'il faut mieux prévenir que
guérir objective à présent franchir le
cap des 1500 adhérents d'ici la fin 2013
Santé Active dispose d'une antenne à
Poissy à Versailles et prochainement à
50 ans en Yvelines sentez-vous sport
deuxième édition un rendez-vous qui est
entendu montrer à la capacité du sport
associatif à attisser du lien partout en
France dans un esprit de rencontre et
d'animation pour tous les publics à la
base de loisirs elle les sportifs
curieux ont découvert le PTK un filet de
badminton au volant mais pas de raquette
le reportage d'Anthony Reich
rassurez-vous votre téléviseur est bien
réglé ces quatre joueurs n'ont pas de
raquette et pourtant il semble bien sur
un terrain de badminton mais il s'essaye
à la PTK dans un se joue avec un filet
de badminton et le principe c'est
d'arriver à marquer le point en faisant
passer le volant de l'autre côté donc du
filet avec un maximum de trois passes de
chaque côté du terrain
pour marquer un point il faut que la PTK
ce gros volant à plume touche le sol et
ici c'est la paume de la main qui sert
de raquette même si la précision n'est
pas toujours au rendez-vous et la main
un peu fatiguée après quelques matchs le
concept est adopté j'ai vraiment
découvert aujourd'hui je savais même pas
que ça existait donc vraiment découverte
totale aujourd'hui et je pense à refaire
un vaisseau sans hésiter c'est pas plus
dur que le badminton et le volet mais il
y a des automatismes acquérir déjà
oublier qu'on a on n'a pas de raquette
dans la main utiliser uniquement sa main
donc voilà ça vient pas forcément
naturellement mais voilà au bout de d'un
peu de temps et d'un peu de pratique je
pense qu'on s'amuse assez rapidement la
PTK est originaire du Brésil mélange de
volley-ball et de badminton ce sport
traditionnel est le plus populaire après
le football et s'il n'y a pas encore de
fédération en France Nicolas et Muriel
entendent bien devenir de vrais matchs
de PTK
d'épuration de Maurepas afin de tout
vous expliquer Olivier Maniscalco et
Anthony Rech
depuis 92 la station d'épuration du
cirque collecte et traite les eaux usées
des communes de Coignières Élancourt et
Maurepas au delavage ou ménagères aux
des toilettes ou d'origine industrielle
la station peut collecter les eaux usées
de près de 47 000 personnes par jour
l'assainissement débute par un
pré-traitement où les plus gros déchets
sont récupérés en supprimant ensuite les
graisses très toxiques et les matières
lourdes comme le sable et la terre
les eaux usées sont ensuite réparties
vers les bassins d'aération où elles
passeront 20h sur les 24 que nécessitent
le traitement global
dans ses bassins la dépollution et
biologiques ce sont les bactéries que
l'on peut apercevoir en surface qui vont
servir de filtres elles vont se nourrir
de la boue présente dans les eaux usées
et ainsi éliminer tous les toxiques tels
que l'azote le carbone ou le phosphore
une fois dégazé les dernières boules
sont éliminées dans le clarificateur et
purée et traité l'eau peut alors
rejoindre le milieu naturel où elle sera
extraite pour être transformée en eau
potable
après effectivement c'est un autre
métier qui consiste donc à puiser de
l'eau dans les nappes phréatiques et
d'en contrôler la qualité pour ensuite
les acheminer dans des usines d'eau
potable qui elles vont poursuivre en
fait un abattement biologique des
dernières bactéries présentes dans l'eau
potable avant de l'acheminer directement
dans les dans les châteaux d'eau pour
être distribués dans les habitations le
travail aussi c'est de Manon d'améliorer
en fait la qualité de l'eau qui va être
directement rejetée dans les collecteurs
donc c'est un travail à faire aussi bien
auprès des particuliers pour les mettre
en conformité mais également au niveau
des professionnels pour les inciter par
exemple à piéger en fait certains
polluants pour ne pas qu'ils en prennent
directement le chemin des collecteurs et
arrive sur la station d'épuration la
mise en conformité de la collecte des
eaux usées des particuliers des
professionnels et donc à revoir
actuellement le bilan est alarmant
puisqu'on estime à 90% le niveau des
eaux souterraines polluées la moitié des
Eaux et Rivières serait aussi concernée
fin de cette édition du 7 8 et de l'actu
je vous retrouve demain en direct à 18h
excellente soirée sur téléphone